well I brought you a surprise uh that I
that I need you to do something too so
you were talking about me taking stuff
from sets and from Full House you love
memorabilia I love memorabilia and so
this is a cool thing I actually took it
out of a ride at Universal Studios and
your godfather signed it for me so I
need you to sign it for me as well
for John rub for good luck Steven
Spielberg
not cool
if you go on that ride at Universal
Studios there's one missing
[Music]
sorry I just the uh I'm sorry
sorry when was the last time you watched
this movie
recently with my daughters yeah do they
like it or did they get yeah they love
it